the import and export statements allow
you to break up your code in different
files or modules though this is an
official es6 feature it is not
implemented in any browsers natively at
this time but it is implemented in many
transpilers such as babel and web pack
the export statement is used to export
functions object or primitives from a
given file or module you can have
multiple named exports in one file like
this so imagine this is all one file lib
KS and these are all exports we can
export at constant we can export a
function and see these all have
different names then you can import the
functions objects or primitives in
another file so here we're gonna import
part of this module and another file
named main jjs this can be done
individually or all together here we're
importing the exports individually we're
importing just Square and diag
so Peter we're not importing the
square-root constant up here however you
can also import the complete module so
this is how you would do that to import
the complete module you just do import
asterisk as live from limb so now
instead of calling the functions
directly with Square and diag we're
gonna do Lib dot squared live that diag
but now we'll also be able to directly
access the square root constant by doing
Lib dot square root you can also import
with different names so if you have a
really long function name you just put
import really really long module member
name as short name now you just access
it by just typing short name instead of
the watch longer name that it was
originally in the other file now what
I've shown you so far are called named
exports because we're exporting things
with specific names square root explorer
square there's another export syntax
called export default usually you're
going to use this syntax if only one
value is being exported from a file it
is also used to create a fallback value
for a file or module with export default
you can only have one
value be a default Explorer in each
module or file at the beginning of your
file we're saying this is my funky is
you're gonna put export default and then
the function or you could put a class
here and then the entire function or
class when export goes right in these
curly braces so this is going to be your
whole file with all the code right in
here one thing to remember is that you
don't put a semicolon at the end and
then when you're importing it so we're
imagining this is another file called
main 1ks and when you import it's a
little different because when you're
importing a single default export there
are no curly braces around the name so
i'm going to import my funk and you can
see that's different from up here where
you put curly braces around the names of
what you're importing also you can see
the name my funk is not up here so we're
actually giving it a name in this other
file and then we can call that function
here well thanks for watching my name is
beau Carnes don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good